uh
what's going to jump out it's like a
butcher shot a half dead stormtrooper
oh god jesus i knew that was coming how
is that still alive
how is it still alive what part of it
did he come out of
oh wait is that a yeah that's one of
those seismic charges
oh i love that
yeah
oh that'll do it
okay so now the sarlacc has to be done
right now it's dead or it doesn't come
back in sarlacc h2o in 20 years with
busta rhymes or in like episode 12. i
have been every monster inside your
boobs
next to palpatine is just the uh cloned
starlet welcome back to new rockstars
the book of boba fett episode 4 gives
that all sarlacc one final jump scare
while making us wonder if we might now
be looking at boba fett defending
tatooine alongside a gotra that includes
denjarin the mandalorian as well as who
knows else
bo katan kosko reeves sabine wren the
other members of the watch maybe even a
couple of hustlers named han solo and
lando calrissian they ain't too old for
this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
this is wookieleek's new rockstars book
of boba fett after show and our weekly
reaction to the latest in star wars i'm
eric voss my easter egg breakdown for
episode 4 is coming tomorrow but right
now i'm here reacting to this episode
with tommy bechtold tommy thoughts eric
i can't wait to party with you that's a
thundercat reference because he's in
this episode thundercats now star wars
canon yes i love it we filled in a lot
of gaps now uh it seems like we're done
with the flashback this uh we now learn
mid-season this is why we've had so many
of these baths it's my favorite
establishing shot i think it's star wars
just exposition boba lies in his back
the tank
again
undefended again just kind of making a
face like a little bit depending on what
the dream's gonna be
he's got his little snorkel in
but i can't i've tried her like it feels
like his nose is very exposed in that
thing yeah the water's creeping in your
nose like you gotta like um consciously
breathe out through your nose otherwise
yeah you're getting a waterfall and a
sinus wets that's right you don't want
sinus wets we all know those are the
most incurable disease in star wars
canon
you get the star wars wetsuit i mean
this is kind of like um you know in in
sopranos we'd always cut to uh to tony
chatting with dr melfi and it made sense
just kind of like seeing him like
lounging in that chair like we're just
getting to know more of this guy's
issues but it's just so funny to see him
taking a bath to do yes like kelly and i
i we we found out that like some of our
friends just love to take baths and it's
just so
i don't take bats i shower but it's
weird the idea of taking baths
constantly i agree it's very ancient
greek uh very ancient greece uh you know
let us know in the comment section if
you're part of bath culture because i
also do not identify as a bather my
muscular frame does not allow for
tub comfort i'm usually like i create a
suction with the tub
uh very like uh
taft like
tub situation i've been pulled out in a
few times by by tub professionals so you
know i think other than tub girl i may
be the most disturbing person
tommy
it's not fair we're hardly five minutes
in this episode you're already
referencing tub girl
it's too early in the episode we got to
save that like the dirty snl sketches
we've got to save those yeah
the final five minutes
sorry
well that out of the way let's talk
about what happened in this episode
so we open with what seems like our
final tub in adventure
and we find out that uh
but uh boba fett is writing his trusty
bantha and he heads over to jabba the
hutt's palace to try to get his ship
back but unfortunately the place is
heavily guarded but what's by what seems
like unendless swarms of gomorians and
anikdos and transitions everyone's going
in and out of this place so instead of
attacking alone he sees a light in the
sky we hear a familiar flute sound
effect and we realize we are connecting
with a familiar moment from the
mandalorian chapter five that's when
fennec shannon was left dying from that
gut wound uh and we actually see the
same footage of those boots walking up
this is after she was left to die there
by that little jerk toro calacan but uh
now we realize that's probably what
happened it was boba fett and this just
confirms it and he takes her to this uh
well not a hospital not a back to tank
the wound is too serious for that toby
that's right he's gotta take her to a
maz eisley match shop run by the mod
artist played by thundercat
yes suicidal tendencies not that's not a
claim i just made that's the band he was
in uh
no i and and also i like of course they
can't go to a hospital like any good
mafia show or movie like if someone gets
shot you got to take them to like a
veterinarian who's like addicted to
opiates or something like that
there's no way dog sparking in the
background exactly but i did like yeah i
thought this was a cool kind of giving
more depth to these like mod kids that
are running around these cities it's
like oh
that's like okay this is where they're
getting it all done and i like the guy
my favorite guy was the goggles guy
you got both eyes gone and now they're
just goggles droid goggles now i had to
wonder i assumed those were his eyes now
but i wonder if he was just like faking
it like he's like he wanted to fit in
with the mod so he wore these cool
glasses he just he just got some
steampunk glasses and was like my eyes
are modified too calculate they're like
we brad we can see you
saying calculating he's like no that's
my goggle droid okay brad please i'm a
poor family it's not fair
but what i love about this is it gives
us a bit of context to that moment when
stephen f root last episode was saying
like they augment themselves with
cybernetic parts and then both boba and
finnick are like yeah yeah she did the
same thing we know that guy the bassist
who like in between of uh weird
steampunky surgical stuff like he just
started picking up his bass guitar yeah
putting max rebo to shame yeah oh yeah
don't you dare talk about max rebo like
that max is back baby he's still on tour
he never went anywhere what is i wonder
what his what is his deal with uh with
that place is he on like a 10 000 year
contract where he's just gonna like they
they plucked him away from the cantina
and now he's at the sanctuary just
jamming maybe they gave him a better
deal right like he gets uh two bar chips
yeah one for him and his biff and
finally these guys and one for his weird
long ears and legs if you see the max
rebo like he's playing it with his legs
puppet thing that's very disturbing look
up max rebo's real body under the uh
keyboard if you're not uh if you're not
doing that
it's too early in the show for these
things too we got to get past
he makes he makes tough girl look like
audrey hepburn okay
wow
somehow we also offended audrey hepburn
why do we have to bring her into this
right now she's in heaven she's like
she's going to be on this season
i imagine her sipping a martini there i
don't think she'd be she's standing next
to mickey rourke who also has his
augmented goggles on and they're like
he's like mickey why did you bring those
to heaven
we've gotten completely sorry like a
pike train at this point um so we have
now um we're now catching up with boba
fett and finnick shan camp firing we had
a lot of campfire scenes between these
two i could have used with four more
personally um we get to have these
moments with the giant bantha
i just like love seeing boba's like
affinity for animals like he is like a
classic like uh crime boss that like has
no problem killing
living like a sentient beings and like
you know uh you know humans and aliens
but when it comes to an animal he's like
protect them at all costs i mean this is
this is all this is classic tony soprano
right the ducks the horse like he kills
one of his captains is warning over the
fact that he killed a horse for
insurance purposes
that is worse than killing himself he
was a beautiful creature
that's a terrible tony soprano
impression it sounded like oh i thought
it was a plus tommy but he was crying
you're amazing he was crying when he
killed him
which is how i've always been uh but uh
he uh he claims that he is now tired of
this bounty hunter life of doing the
bidding of stupider leaders and now he
wants to head up his own god truck try
his hand at ruling for once uh and he
wants his fire spray gun ship back now
just to clear something up the fire
spray is the type of ship it is it's not
the name of the ship yes it sounds like
they have renamed slave one i don't care
what anyone's opinions are about that
but uh the ship is just a fire spray 31
class patrol and attack craft yeah
that's just to clear up we don't know
what the new name is but they invade
jabba's palace and i love this whole
scene where they run into a chef droid
and then the other droids is called a
sous-chef droid yeah they cleared that
up in the captions yeah and uh that's
that chef droid pulls a general grievous
with his butcher knives but he brought a
butcher knife to a blaster fight or at
least a gappy stick fight or in this
case it was it was been extended just
several years i mean i have never seen a
robot in its throat slashed but i did
not know how badly i did need to see it
you know what i've never seen before is
a uh leptoid a rat catcher yes
sobbing
and depowering himself
don't we all wish every once in a while
we could just go
for a little bit yes but only if there
is a chance to just reboot oneself yes
it's kind of like that i i do really
like that uh uh bo burnham joke where he
you know he's talking pretty
directly about suicide he's like it just
sucks that it's permanent it'd be great
if i could just like skip the next 18
months and just kind of wake up but i
can't and that's what this droid is able
to do he's just able to just extract
himself from this
horrible humiliating moment i thought
that was the most touching moment yes it
was heartbreaking i was worried about
the left droid honestly i was like wait
does that did he just off himself like
yeah for a second it didn't seem that
way
but they managed to get back to boba
fett [ __ ] and they can get out of there
it just seems like a matter of shooting
the right counterweight to open the door
felt very uh legends of the hidden
temple yeah to get out of there but i'm
loving it uh and then um if that says
that shand you know can leave his
service like the the life debt has been
repaid but she's like you know what i'm
gonna i'm gonna hang out and despite
finnett casting doubt that uh the nicto
kenton striders were actually the
killers of the tuscans that doesn't do
any investigation that that uh sigil was
enough proof for him and he goes crazy
on them yes doesn't give them a chance
to explain themselves these guys are
stricken from this world they're gone
this is pretty frightening i have to say
in that finnick
didn't really seem to object at all no
she was like i love this i'll sit
shotgun for this literally who else can
we shoot yeah you wanna just go shoot
some people on the streets of uh maz
eisley it's like now another weird thing
is like we already know the jawas stole
his armor but for some reason boba
fett's like i got to get as close as
freaking possible into this sarlacc's
mouth uh and i want to see its tongue it
seems like he was semi-conscious when
the jawas were taking the armor off him
but look it was it was a traumatic
memory being covered in the stomach acid
of that sarlacc in on those sands maybe
he just blacked out and he was
dehydrated and one of the symptoms of
dehydration is hallucination so there is
a quite a possibility that he was like i
i mean medically as much as i have no
idea what clones symptoms are to you
know the effects of the twin sons of
tatooine are you it would stand to
reason that his memory's a little uh
fuzzy from
the point where he escaped on i just
want to know how this sarlacc is still
alive michael myers yeah yeah we didn't
see him like actually claw his way out
of the sarlacc's belly yeah now it just
seems like he was a bit of acid reflux
burp up yeah
i imagine him clawing through his
stomach lining through his intestines
wherever he was uh through flesh through
layers of muscle until he got through
the skin and broke through right using
fire and whatever but no that wasn't the
case he just kind of got burped up and
that even the sarlacc's limp uh tentacle
was on the sand and now that sarlacc was
seemed pretty healed
sarlacc was in a back to tank he had
even bigger backpack where the sarlacc
would have dreams of his traumatic past
oh well that's no that's what
rick and morty would do that rick and
morty would have it retreat into a
different
tank and then show it getting raised by
a different tribe or being uh taught the
customs of a different tribe now i i i
was gonna say like you know it is the
horror movie trope that if you don't
actually see
the full death on screen it's not dead
so i feel like with the uh with the
seismic charge it's definitely dead now
but yeah and i love bringing back that
seismic charge from attack of the clones
i just love that sound effect like that
could be if you could just put that on
repeat that'd be white noise for me yeah
it just gives me some ass that's my look
yeah i was gonna say that's my asmr as
well
so we jump back to the president we're
above fed heads to garcia whips club the
sanctuary to you know take in some of
those uh max rebo tunes he's on his a
third wave of his career he's doing his
best work um
and we see like black chrysanthemum just
go crazy in this club he we see him
another kind of like tony soprano type
thing where he's just watching people
have fun and then suddenly snaps uh
where he's like watching these gambling
transitions now why why does he hate the
trained oceans well i we do we got to
remember dr strassley the leader of the
transitions these people hunt wookies he
brought in a wookie pelt as a tribute to
boba fett uh i think black or santa
knows that so he doesn't even like take
the amazing offer of uh of gossip whip
offering to clear his bar tab and he
just rips the guy's arm off but it would
not be a proper gathering on a tattooing
unless someone's arm got ripped that's
true that's very true uh tommy you said
maybe he just hates gambling it could be
that uh yeah maybe he's got maybe he
about he abides to a very king james uh
christian bible
strict interpretation
and and thinks games of chance are
forbidden right he his life was ruined
he had a wife who got in it with the
sharks and they cut up her face and
that's how he got these scars yeah
he just wanted to show her that he could
still smile
that's a different one every time
well outside the club boba offers bk a
job on his team and bk just does one of
these like
okay
i'm in
you son of a [ __ ] i'm in
that's how i want them to recruit the
rest of their gang it's just going on i
wanted the montage i wanted them a
grouper montage that ended with all
these people in a ship that just
explodes so the boba fett goes oh no no
no no no
[Music]
are you okay
so we see this one last scene that we've
seen in a trailer footage of the big
family dinner table right with all the
different leaders of the families uh
including finally those crazy old
platoonians uh and then boba requests
that if they aren't gonna help him in
his war to at least stay neutral against
the pike syndicate we'll see how long
that pledge neutrality lasts but all
they really need is a little
encouragement from the terrifying
10-foot wookie that's standing behind
them and the fact that this table is
right above the gate for the rancor pit
and that rancor i thought it was a a
deeper pit that right here seemed like
he jumped up
you know
maybe maybe maybe maybe his trainer was
just like lifting him like like yeah
giving him a boost trey goes down there
beneath the rank or like come on get
your claws through the grate trejo's
buff on all those trejo tacos he's been
consuming
man trejo's tacos
the best best breakfast burrito in los
angeles anyway uh so as fett says that
he needs more muscle for the war fenix
says she knows where to find some muscle
and we hear the music from the
mandalorians suggesting din jaren is
going to be on the call sheet next
episode and we are so excited yes but
our merch partners at epic hero shop
have a new shirt in their latest
obsession series inspired by the book of
boba fett these are limited editions uh
that spider-man no way home shirt are
already sold out so grab one of these
boba vet shirts before they are gone and
when you grab a latest obsession shirt
you'll get the added option right in a
custom shout out that will appear at the
bottom of these book of boba fett after
shows we got danny who says finnick
shand let black kersanton in to kill
boba hashtag mephisto hot take um yeah
someone uh someone was sleeping on the
job yeah i think for sure
well you know the two half the guard are
teenagers and the other half are thick
thick big men so
you know it stands to reason that the
teenagers were flirting with each other
the thick boys were flirting with each
other who knows maybe it was just a
little bit of a casual friday when bk
stepped in and choked out bubba
yeah you know what you know what smooch
on your own time this is company time
yeah yeah you know what boss makes a
dollar i make a dime that's why i smooch
on company type
well brian says just a fellow uf alum
buying some sweet sweet merch love y'all
well we love you brian go gators and uh
paul says thank you eric and tommy my
dad and i have been bonding more over
the new star wars and marvel shows paul
i love hearing that kind of stuff that's
really nice people are coming together
over these shows that's how your dad
said hello hey tell your dad i said it
all
well check out all of our awesome merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com all
right tommy let's dive into it what's
the big question coming out of this
episode eric
who the fact will boba fett and fenik
shan recruit to fight the pikes
yes uh that is the question fenix says
credits can buy muscle if you know where
to look and right after fenix says this
we hear that familiar music let's roll
the clip
[Music]
yes yes that is live goranton's flute
theme from the mandalorian the music of
denjarin now again a reminder of this
episode we have now seen all the footage
that has appeared in promos we are in
the blind now people and in these final
three episodes it's all gonna be new
unseen footage that could mean the
remaining three episodes heavily feature
this newcomer now when we last saw
denjarin at the end of the mandalorian
season two he uh was breaking our hearts
into a thousand pieces by giving grogu
to luke skywalker to complete his jedi
training and he has possession of the
dark saber which seemed to set up a bit
of tension between him and bogatan that
was the weapon she was really in this
for um but it doesn't seem like he has
taken over as automatic leader to
mandalore yet these are civilized uh
complex people they're just gonna look
at a sword and be like oh he's he's boss
now okay but it will go a long way into
his claim if he wants that throne right
now that he does it doesn't seem like
that's anything he's he tries to
immediately give bokutan the darksaber
and she's like yeah not that way homie
no i have to kill you i have to beat you
i do have to slit your throat to get
this
um but i think that was setting up a
future for
mandalorian season three the title of
that show is a mandalorian they made it
clear the book of boba fett is not just
you know the next chapter of the
mandalorian but he is going to cross
into it so i think this is going to be
uh kind of a mandalorian
season 2.5 right so it's going to set up
what happens in the mandalorian season
three so this is going to be some kind
of side quest that he's now joining boba
fett on um we also remember that poketan
initially got into a brawl with boba
fett in that cafe she considered she
considered him a false mandalorian a
clone was committing a kind of stolen
valor doesn't deserve to be wearing that
best car armor but in fact django fett
was a clone he raised boba fett as a son
jango fett was a mandalorian i should
say uh they have a chain code that dates
them back to jester murreal from concord
dawn who was a different division of the
mandalorians uh the true mandalorians as
opposed to the death watch or the watch
what is now the night owls of bogotan
and uh costco reeves but we should also
remember it seems like someone else is
out there sabine wren uh that's who was
joining ahsoka tano in their search at
the end of rebels and she has her
connection of course with the
mandalorians another thing that we
should remind ourselves of is that uh
dave felloni himself will be directing
at least one episode this season and
normally he'll come in to direct
something as you saw in uh in the
mandalorian the ahsoka episode someone
who it's a live ad it's a live-action
adaptation of a character of one of the
animated series that he deeply cares
about getting right so i have to wonder
if one of these characters is going to
be from that world if it was just a
matter of didn't jarring i think they
could entrust uh
john favreau who writes all these
episodes and robert rodriguez who
directed a number of the mandalorian
episodes to do it um but we have to
wonder now who is really controlling
mandalore and why
characters like bokutan and denjarin
might want to help boba fett maybe if he
could say you scratch my back right now
on tatooine i'll scratch your back on
mandalore i'll help you retake that
planet that's how they can
pull those levers of power to get them
on their side in this temporary fight
with the pikes it could be revealed that
maybe the pikes are the ones controlling
mandalore at the present moment we
thought it was maf gideon but all we
know is that he's the one who like
sacked the planet and raided them of
their relics we don't know who's
currently controlling it it seems like
the pikes are incredibly powerful uh
they have kind of filled the vacuum here
of power here in the universe as the
empire is still picking up pieces um but
it could also be revealed if it's just
the pikes i just think the pikes are
kind of
i'm sorry if you are pike stands i think
the pikes are kind of boring villains
yeah
i'd like them better as like cogs in a
machine who are constantly like serving
different leaders and playing all sides
of the war i'd be more interested if a
group like the crimson don
is really controlling mandalore at the
present moment just because kira has
like not force capabilities but she has
a lightsaber training you know that was
a big thing that she learned from maul
uh so i think that be an exciting uh big
bad behind who's currently on the throne
of mandalore that's who they're gonna
try to defeat on the mandalorian and
that's who also the pikes are working
for that can hopefully be something that
is revealed on the show if not that's
okay my theories are often wrong um
uh just kind of run through a couple
other options who could join this gotra
uh who is motivated by money in this
world or could be convinced to join boba
fett's family what we got bill burr has
meg's mayfield still floating around
somewhere out there that guy just throw
a sack full of money at him i mean he is
technically dead did die in an explosion
according to uh the lie that's been made
that he's high he's presumed dead right
that is his uh history i mean he isn't
really dead but he's pretending right
right but that's yeah he's he's a
free actor you can go wherever it's kind
of like there's a benefit to people
thinking you're dead as both that
explains that's right um there's also
the possibility that omega could show up
in live action uh that could be the
cameo that dave filoni wants to get
right you know like uh omega is
technically a clone sister to uh to boba
fett i don't know if they know each
other i don't know if she would care
about helping him defend tatooine's
crime organization to just work
independently from a non-corporate
arrangement um um but there are you know
these rumors that people like han solo
maybe lando calrissian could show up are
do you think they'd pull just the same
trick of de-aging harrison ford the way
they did with mark hamill that is the
rumor that is going around is that he
that that he was on set for uh for some
filming so i don't know if that that's
true but if if that is the case yeah i
think they would de-age him right but
the problem is his voice is so
much deeper now like hamill's voice got
deeper but he can still kind of he's
such a gifted voice actor he can kind of
catch it up a little bit
i don't know if
harrison ford's voice is currently like
this it's gonna like you know
it's gonna if he's gonna be able to do
it i mean obviously they could find a
voice match too you know there's enough
talented impersonate impersonators of
the impressionists right
out there but yeah i don't know i don't
know if i need han solo in this
adventure you know i think there's other
fun people that could get involved i
mean obviously i'll take any han solo i
can get but i just sure i don't know i'm
not sure yeah i guess my question would
be like logically han solo uh he for a
time
stayed with leia they were raising a son
right um
ben solo around this time i don't know
why he would leave that yeah has been
ben would have been
oh i guess maybe ben might not have been
born yet i think ben was born in 10 aby
which would be right after so this would
be his this is like this is his bachelor
party this is
i mean he is
they're like they got to be settling
down right
in the new republic so i don't know why
they convinced him to be like hey help
us fight this uh crime boss versus crime
boss war i don't know if han would be
interested in that but anyway uh let's
talk about what a gotra okay that word
gets dropped this episode and it's
interesting how they frame it that way
because that's what fenix says when he's
like oh you want to hit a gatra and
we've heard gatra in star wars before in
mandalorian chapter nine gore koresha
was like zama's character says he swears
by the gotra that he knew of someone on
uh in mandalorian armor in the city of
mas pelago on tatooine uh there's also
been mention of a droid gotra in the
2014 tarkin novel in the dr aphra and
darth vader comics that's a group of
droids supporting droid rights but gatra
is actually a sanskrit term in hindi
culture referring to a lineage kind of
like a family tree or a dynasty it's
more complex than that i'm just giving
you the shorthand of it um but
contextually fenix shand is kind of
asking boba if he wants to start
essentially a new house of boba how
simple
father son and house of bulba
oh lady gaga's got to get involved
it's interesting that she frames it away
because the guy is a clone
genealogically speaking but would his
house his gotcha be made of genealogical
ties like other clones that might still
be out there like omega or his ancestral
roots through the mandalorian lineage
like and that would connect him
potentially with bo katan with sabine
with dinjarin the watch the other
mandalorians that are out there uh uh or
perhaps his newfound family
of criminals through the remnants of
jabba's cartel
well you know what yeah why not i mean
this maybe this is all about the family
you choose you know maybe this gatra is
you know heroes are not heroes but you
know bounty hunters for hire i mean boss
has to be out there somewhere you know
uh yeah doing heists maybe we get him
maybe you get those uh those like cowboy
droids at the bounty hunt i you know i i
think
i don't know necessarily that this has
to have anything genealogical i think
this is this is the new air i think this
is you know star wars is always at its
best when it's making a commentary on
real life right like it's always kind of
fun when it's like kind of related and i
think maybe this is all about boba fett
finding a family you know a man who's
not alone his entire life finding people
that he actually genuinely trusts like
he seems to really actually trust fennec
shand right now despite yes one an
alliance based on loyalty right that's
that's a pretty powerful thing in this
corner so maybe not bosk then maybe boss
would be a bad choice
i mean look if he can flip black santa
and he can slip boss the problem is you
can't have those people sitting at the
same table wow yeah i mean it seems like
but they have there is precedent they
have worked together in the comics so
you know maybe maybe when there's money
involved chris santan's like i
i i can look past the fact that i hate
this
this transition who's whose people have
hunted down my people for centuries so
maybe maybe he'll let it slide for the
right amount of coin you know
yeah um i'm just curious to see like
he's fighting an army yeah so
you know in the past uh star wars is
like oh we have an army of clones that
is uh secretly being bred on uh camino
they can help fight your war for you
even if it's just like individuals on a
team this isn't like you have a team
that you put together you need like
sections divisions of people to fight
this war so i'm kind of curious to see
you know are is there just like an army
of mercenaries out there that finnick
knows about that we don't know about
that's about yeah you know it's kind of
or it's like the uh game of thrones um
when uh when uh when the uh the vale
joins uh
yeah or like the unsullied or something
like that yeah it's like he's like yeah
who who could be brought they are gonna
eventually need to beef up their numbers
it can't just be like six badass
fighters because then it turns into like
you know they're just gonna get it's
like the 300 they're just yeah that's
why i think it's gonna be like uh
whoever the members of the watch the
other mandalorian groups that are still
out there he's gonna make an agreement
with them saying help me fight this war
i'll use my forces from defeating the
pikes to help you retake mandaloria and
that propels cara dune apologizes or is
on her best behavior
she can fly in
say something offensive
stop comparing just like through the
platoon genocide
you know instead of
you know
her uh her own opinions but we don't
have to dive into that
uh oh it's too late we already have the
top girl i met tub girl maybe
yes
oh my god
but before we continue with the rest of
this episode today's episode is
sponsored by honey we all shop online
and we've all seen that promo code feel
just taunt us at checkout but thanks to
honey manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free browser extension that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies
the best one it finds to your cart when
you're checking out on a shopping site
the honey button drops down and all you
have to do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons and if it finds a working coupon
you'll watch the prices drop we all use
honey around the office off-screen
producer brandon recently saved five
bucks on a food delivery and editor john
saved ten percent on a new jacket honey
has found its over 17 million members
over two billion dollars in savings if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up missing out on some free
savings it's literally free and installs
in a few seconds and by getting it
you'll be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this show so get honey for
free at joinhoney.com
wookie with one e that's joinhoney.com
wookie also thanks to bluetooth for
sponsoring this episode we're pretty
confident in our theories here on
wikileaks and confidence can take you
pretty far in life and in the bedroom
that's where blue chew comes in blue
chew is unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can plan ahead or be ready for
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days it's all done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package so if you
could benefit from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform bluetooth can
help and we've got a special deal for
our audience try bluetooth for free when
you use our promo code new rockstars at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluechu.com promo code
new rockstars to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the show and we want to thank babel for
sponsoring this episode lots of us have
goals for this year at the top of lots
of our list is learning a new language
with babel the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions the whole babble process
is addictively fun fast and easy babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use two of our editors at new
rockstars are currently using babel to
learn spanish they're racing each other
to see who can get fluent first and they
both love the app babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babel lessons
were created by over 100 language
experts and have been scientifically
proven to be effective with babble you
can choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babble speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and your accent there are
so many ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcasts games videos stories even live
classes plus it comes with a 20-day
money-back guarantee start your new
language learning journey today with
babel right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com and use the promo
code wookiee that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code wookie babble
language for life so tommy i wanted to
ask you what the fed are the pikes
plotting at this point in star wars
history how do they get so powerful what
is their end goal well this is uh a lot
like uh dune in the sense that he who
controls the spice controls the gala it
controls the world or whatever controls
the universe yeah i think that they are
amassing resources they're taking
they're taking planets and they're
draining the planets of their resources
stripping them of any of their value and
moving on like they are they are the
colonizers they are the like you know
they're they're going into the diamond
mines taking all the diamonds and just
leaving wreckage you know
again i think kind of a commentary on
things that have historically really
happened in in in the world so i think
what they're plotting is to amass a
tremendous amount of wealth and fill the
power vacuum you know the the the empire
is presumably
down now we know that there's a dark uh
uh a first order rising but we don't
know where that is right now so i think
that maybe they're establishing
themselves as the new galactic overlords
you know through wealth rather than
through destruction and through through
through war i think they're they're
they're doing the old money talks
uh yeah this is what you typically see
in history once the political order gets
revolutionized overturned in some way
the next most organized group arguably
who was more organized than the
political structure or the criminal
elements right who uh honestly the
political order in this case kind of
used to keep order in certain things
it's like that line from target oh the
regional governors will keep them and
you know like they kind of rely on
decentralized thing and then the fear of
the death star being the ultimate
centralization to keep people in line
right um but now the the pikes through
their uh clever scheming and their
that's the organization like we'll work
with you we'll work with you now you two
kill each other and we'll take what both
of you have yeah i want to know still
how the huts fit into all this if they
truly do fear the pikes if they're
secretly working with the pikes uh or if
they're hoping that uh boba fett will
have some loyalty to them as a result of
this rank or gift yeah um
i i want to shout out our uh friends of
new rock stars uh joanna robinson and
mallory rubin over at the ringer verse
who are so great in their analysis i
would i would check out their after
shows they're so thoughtful in the way
they go through these episodes uh but
one theory that they brought up was this
idea that because tatooine used to be
covered in vast oceans the pikes if you
do consider them an aquatic species
who have to wear these special breathing
masks usually when they're in the spice
mines
um and when they're on this planet they
need water to survive that maybe this
could be their native land it's gonna be
something that's a diaspora or some sort
of ancestral place
but originally they were on tatooine
they're trying to reclaim this is why
that's really fast
i feel like they brought it up multiple
times that the planet of tattooing needs
to be covered yes that has that seems to
be the entire like geographic history of
tattooing seems to have been brought up
you know over and over they keep
mentioning the dune c and things like
that so yeah i think that that does make
sense yeah i mean if it's not that i i
hope that they have some kind of
explanation for why they keep bringing
this up other than the fact that it's
just like
geographically and anthropologically
interesting yeah i wonder if they'll
like hit like a water spring or
something at some point like a blaster
will hit like the sand and water will
bubble up and it'll be the beginning of
something like that i don't know
i guess we will see um one last question
i want to ask you tom this whole moment
where boba fett gets revenge on the
kenton striders
massacre these kitten striders uh
without really any proof other than the
sigil without someone else taking credit
using their logo
did he commit like a kind of uh uh
war crime yeah i don't know if you'd
call this a war crime
but
it's tough to it would be tough to argue
against that i mean the thing about it
is you know boba fett was kind of a
merciless bounty hunter before
this transformation he had with the
tuscan raiders and you know there's a
chance that this you know
he was looking for some
thing or someone or some people to take
out his aggression on and his anger and
his grief so maybe
even though he didn't you know know with
with absolute certainty
that it was uh that it was the nicto
biker gang it was enough for him to
you know do some healing by blasting uh
and yeah i just i just don't know how we
as viewers were meant to feel yeah while
watching it definitely because it bumped
me if if we were meant to be like hell
yeah why would they include that line
from finnick earlier in the episode
where she's like speed bikers to beat
the tuscans that's highly unlikely i
wonder if
although it feels as though we're done
with back to flashbacks i wonder if
there will be
some more
um
evidence of the nikta uh biker gang nick
i'm sorry the nickdoe uh biker gang
uh
messing with boba fett more or like i
mean he did witness them
or what appeared to be them like you
know raiding that moisture farmer's
house too so he has seen them do messed
up seeing them do bad things he saw them
screwing with uh with cammy yeah um you
know like
sure i just think
not that that justifies blasting them
yeah yeah i mean look these guys are
jerks you know they they
there's a good chance they were the ones
who murdered the uh the tuscans there i
just think it's an example of how star
wars likes to just like point in lots of
different directions and say look the
world's just a complicated complicated
place it's the code breaker maybe
they're maybe they're setting us up for
some benicio del toro uh weapons
i sell to these people i sell to these
people and uh they're both on both sides
so um but i did find that interesting
that they would include that line i also
found it interesting that uh boba fett
would call them sand people oh yeah and
fenix shin is the one who calls him
tuscans yeah like i you would think that
would be reverse that boba after
spending all this time with him would
learn maybe just star wars is not saying
that is the slur that we have been
saying it is it's just a common term
yeah they're they're they're done with
naming the ship slave one but they're
doubling down
on sand people
complex world it's a complex universe
out there it's all folks guys takes all
folks glad i have you with me to
navigate it me too that is it for this
episode of wikileaks again the easter
egg breakdown is coming tomorrow and
tommy and i will be back next wednesday
with our reaction to chapter five of the
book of boba fett don't forget to check
out our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at ea boss follow tommy at
tommybechdel follow new rockstars
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts thank you for watching we
have spoken
you